où
quand j'étais quatre hommages chantant
sur bateau avec un dans les poches
faisait moins la fine bouche ce poney
toutes les avances de sourire patrick
asch fallait bien que je mange pour
apaiser ma soif on triplet dessert je
recule et la tante du groove entre art
empire avec chansons balancent sur mon
l'estrade en top que je prenais pour
celles je sentais comme un coq est
fautif sur la scène quand j'étais
personnes plein de petites aphtes
automne je rêvais
je me voyais des gens
quand j'avais personne qu'une soif qui
débat j'avais dit au genou et déjà et
c'est et pauvre début début des vues au
au début
acquis au pinceau sur le bon mariage
avec costumes si lyon et l'odeur du
fromage
j'ai posé comme il faut les gens me
n'est pas là je me sentais pas photo
entre les noyades
j'ai dit lui qu'on ne voit pas qui du
centre l'étape entendu rihanna avec un
accent grave qui sourit à chaque fois
pour faire plusieurs mais ne faudrait
pas que messieurs ce sont mes parents
quand j'étais personnes
plein de petites afd automne très raide
idole je me voyais des gens
quand j'avais personne qu'une soif qui
débat
j'avais des tonnes je me voyais déjà
essai du bo
début début du début au début
beau début début du camp gt4 hommage
chantons sur bateau mouche avec un dans
les poches vous et moi la fine bouche
prenez toutes les avances de sourire pas
très cash fallait bien que je mange pour
apaiser ma soir
bateaux mouches c'est arrivé parce que
c'était un truc hyper fort de mon
histoire d'avant et qu'ils se trouvent
re re re situe un peu comment je suis
arrivé là je suis pas arrivé sous
blister n'y a pas eu un truc d'or et
voilà premier album mais il ya eu un des
étapes
l'évolution se voulait poser avec cette
chanson un beau un joli regard avec un
un peu de tendresse et de mélancolie
dessus c'était que on dit souvent âgés
galéré c'était c'était dur fallait y
aller tout le dur il fallait y aller
tous les soirs il y avait un truc un peu
routinier et c'était hyper formateurs
tous les soirs fallait se donner la mort
et tout pour aller attraper les gens qui
réagissait pas et tout du coup je
voulais montrer sans regret sans sans
cracher dans la soupe je voulais montrer
cette histoire qui était un peu
intrigante est qui et qui un peu ce hors
du commun au tout début c'était pas
j'étais hyper content de pouvoir déjà
fermé premier cachet de pouvoir monter
sur scène même si c'était une toute
petite scène on était très serré de
monter sur scène chaque soir mais je
savais que pour moi c'était une un
passager que je voulais aller encore
beaucoup plus loin quoi
on m'invite au ceser 2019 pour rendre
hommage à charles aznavour et je crois
que c'est dans la même veine que j'ai
écrit le texte bateau mouche
du coup je pense qu'il ya une résonance
c'est un hommage un peu déguiser le côté
être personne ya ce côté un peu tournure
de phrase qui est très d'époque en plus
qui moi me parlait beaucoup parce que je
le dis comme ça dans mon par les communs
mais c'est plutôt une image une
référence dans le sens connu pas connu
le le switch entre le fait d'être
présentés publiquement et le fait de pas
l'être le fait d'avoir certaines
certains privilèges aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis de mon statut et et pas avant
il ya des choses qui certes ont changé
c'est ça que je voulais un peu mentionné
après le fait de devenir quelqu'un chez
eux il ya cette notion de réussite qui
pour moi n'est jamais acquise c'est
toujours un truc en continuellement qui
doit staff et qui va se redessiner qui
va se préciser et et je sais pas si on
peut établir comme ça le truc de la
réussite j'ai réussi je crois pas que
c'est un truc qui qui m'ont en tout cas
même c'est pas un arrêt en arrêt là
maintenant
[Musique]